[Music]
in caught red-handed new handed
submitted by your a star your star
you're a moon oh my god I would hate to
be here girl God to give its arm eyes
you're a moon black hole your asteroid
oh [ __ ] okay you're dead top must be
weird did you like this [ __ ] do you
like my weird okay a team suspected of
million-dollar fraud is found writing
his to-do list when the cause blast him
with their search warrant Tom mother
to-do list for robbing sucks really was
organized is he shouldn't go to jail cuz
he has a [ __ ] to-do list
well no he already got a million dollars
he needs to you the team that's an
accomplishment
how did how did he get the million
dollars should I say anyway Nancy he is
a little [ __ ] walter white man cut
your lot do you [ __ ] get whatever
money and it's tough you need anymore
man if I was a teenager I got a million
points I would just cut I'm done I'm
good a million bucks that'll ask me a
long way but he could be out chapo I
don't want to be our chapo I just want
to be el dedo El Chapo can be on the
Forbes list of hunt hundred two women in
the world
Chapel Hill chill it's up to you today
oh just oh yeah this kid 19 year old
Billy stone is his name was dope it is
pretty damn it what's up really strong
system
last name is Dow no he's not a first
name silly so listen Atlanta was stoned
the last name is tur mine so we thought
about that yes Souter my it got to our
mind with the teeth it just sounds like
you [ __ ] termite stones what is he
like Malaysian or howling a final like a
scientific name or something I mean that
right there's a Phyllis tone to mine so
I'll show you about is black I know it
looks like you Lum bein Dominican may be
fun he has a yes he has the eyes of a
mother plane bro you got a million dogs
but you can't get a line up god damn bro
he look cool he looks like he just
popped out of the eighties I know my
father he got to get that [ __ ] lined up
oh man that should look like a broken
cookie look it hasn't broken could look
at it from an 80s 80s perspective he
looks cool like if you handsome boy
though I'll give him that just fix that
hairdo Terrace down this is just too
Wiggly away you know what when you're
entrepreneur like that and you're making
millions you don't care what you look
like because you just stacking it up
dude sure yeah [ __ ] you are too busy
yeah so this kid woody ended up doing
not going stuff like he was huh yeah
pretty much
you hacker yeah Eckhart that's dope dude
you doing smart way to be doing why are
you shady why does he say to you did
involves converting the modern tax
return scam into unemployment benefits
so that modern tax return scam is where
hackers get your personal information
and they submit a tax form yeah I could
do your taxes and then they receive the
refund instead of you so they just put a
fake numbers so then but then he that
I'd be very thankful cause he did my
taxes for me you don't get your returns
yeah but at the same time at least I'm
not getting hounded by the IRS yes your
irons like cool yeah yeah so then what
do you do do you use names and Social
Security numbers and he got yeah so he
got benefit and he
name 1 million 19 thousand eight hundred
and fifty nine dollars in benefits from
March 2015 through May 2016 majek so he
ended up using or he made the filing
through two different internet provider
addresses the payment link to his home
oh boy
yeah so then Martin it was the most
basic [ __ ] that [ __ ] Trumpton yeah
but it took him a long time to catch him
uh he wasn't caught recently he was
caught back in 2016
oh man I would have just took that money
and disappear dude because he'd been
doing that remotely he could do that
anywhere across the world it doesn't
matter what are you doing yeah I like
this guy why I go to jail he's ruining
people's lives I think you guys could
search the videos that we just had you
just said sneaky shady people with
scammers yeah you just said it what are
you talking about he's not really a
scammer though he is a scam it's a
little different it's probably searching
the web finding random people's
information in the dark web you should
know them you know it's different when
you know someone and then you try to
backstab them and that's a truce camera
these people don't even know that their
taxes are being filed yeah she's a
undercover accountant like he's like oh
there goes David again didn't [ __ ]
file his taxes in April let me do it for
him you know what that is though it's
kind of just like he's actually doing
something in return though because they
get their taxes done right and he did it
to the best of his ability but he gets a
fat return they get it the money but
yeah if she says you know they're
decaying they're over there telling this
CIA needs to hire him yeah so then uh
they the cops they went over there they
had a search warrant once they arrived
in the home they found him in his
bedroom listening to music through his
ear buds and right there people tonight
I'd like that child
and then they found him writing his
summer to do it
what is it entail with that book that
was ever caught in bed like this with
his legs kicking up and he's like
listening to music like yeah make money
but [ __ ] that one it's a really bad
photo yeah so this is his summer to do
it summer 2016 we have to do it in 2016
actually I had written yeah I have a
girl kids
yeah maternal [ __ ] loser just kidding
journals are cool yeah I did Senate
slash across a [ __ ] off the to-do list
said by online Marek b NK & c CBS that's
what he wrote so that means by a Merrick
bank card fake credit card numbers and
the security code on the back of them
through the dark web so he's trying to
obtain credit cards and the C CDs and
the other thing on his list was buy
three phones one clean to dirty whoa
to-do list
can you can't memorize that what do I
need a pen aside I'm or did this I need
D order and I'm curious what else you
wanted to write though I never benefited
Anila oh I thought that was his whole
list it was like Waco dambly make sure
my eyes are most Abbas you only funny in
that list it was like to shaping's and
like won by bubblegum yes women get milk
yeah damn you when they found him next
to him on the bed or three cell phones
and a laptop and then hittin in between
the mattress and the boxspring there
were debit and credit cards that weren't
his and it didn't belong to anyone else
that lived with him and blank white
plastic cards with magnetic strips and
so sighs honestly get ahold of this you
just learn how to do that yeah
obviously and but they are mentioning
that he needed the equipment necessary
equipment to actually encode the
magnetic strip on the credit or debit
card Danny be do Schumer thought the
house crazy Jenna how so are one thing a
car he was sentenced to four and a half
years in federal prison for aggravated
identity theft and access device fraud
to a federal prison there's a lot better
than the regular [ __ ] so that's that
that's a white what's it called why
college the other
he said he's 20 years old 19 oh there's
some reason I don't think he's a bad guy
me neither what he's a bad guy are you
envious of him like you wish you were
him and you were able to do evening at
19 no there's just certain times
glorified it I'm not glorified but I
think he is a loophole finder and that's
why I see the CIA me stuff he doesn't
hurt my feelings how can we then speak
like [ __ ] twins because we're
criminal one guy starts to sentence so
it was on Joe and then your finishing is
[ __ ] yeah former criminals and we
know a real criminal when we see one
there's one that's like okay you really
use your brain and you're kind of you
just you all of the laws the same way
you don't like petty scammers you like
people who are like geniuses I don't
like people that [ __ ] with your emotions
[ __ ] with my money it's [ __ ] with
my emotions your [ __ ] trust and then
they [ __ ] you all you don't like can
see mother yeah I don't like that I
don't like those people what I don't
mind uniting people you know like
conniving people having mother [ __ ]
bath well like if someone wears a was to
have to bank database right and then
from my account money goes away I'll be
like [ __ ] that was dope no one gets hurt
my account is uh it's easier yeah it's
insured $400 you thank you
yeah sure for a hundred thousand and I
don't have anywhere near a hundred
thousand and that thing so but these
people are losing their tax returns some
people actually depend on at exercise
yeah use a thousand people's
region though a thousand people equal a
million families lots of money problem
really nobody's a victim here family
very much murder yes I don't get the
return oh yeah that's what my why are
you glorifying his kid he's stealing for
himself you know when I used to work I
just forgot about the tax returns and if
they appeared then I'm like lucky day
and if it didn't can I forgot
I was like that this sure sure I forgot
I was [ __ ] like on my money zero did
you don't get for like a month or two
yeah I was lost
I'm everyday the thing is that he used
that same scam but not for the tax
return thing he did it for unemployment
benefit that's what he was taking money
from like people that were receiving
unemployment benefit mmm no and on
average is what thousand bucks per
person cuz it's a thousand people
probably yeah mmm so smart quiet easy
thanks living my dream though what like
just having a million bucks I can't even
get to touch it I know but if he did I
didn't even touch the money I'm assuming
okay got caught and what's not you sexy
[ __ ] useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to follow us you could check
out all our [ __ ] links in the
description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
you
[Music]